will mir hier jemand meine
lieblingssportart vermiesen ich glaube
fußball ist die pest von heute ich
verachte die leute die zu solchen
spielen gehen genauso wie die
überbezahlten halbstarken auf dem platz
wurde die ferien egomanen die diese so
genannten klubs manager dies die worte
einer polizistin im krimi winter
transfer von philip k
und das buch ist gespickt mit solch
bissigen kommentaren
doch wie sich herausstellt ist kirk ein
verächter des fußballs ganz im gegenteil
bereits hat der vielschreiber zwei
weitere bände seiner fußball krimis
verfasst wir treffen uns in seinem
lieblingslokal an bester londoner lage
ich halte den fußball für untere
präsentiert was gute literatur geht
darum wollte ich es selbst probieren
es herrscht offenbar dieses gefühl vor
dass der durchschnitts fällen nicht
gerne liest oder literatur interessiert
ist das glaube ich einfach nicht
wintertransfer spielt im umfeld der
englischen premier-league einer
geldmaschine die jährlich milliarden
pfund umsetzt
der trainer eines fiktiven vereinsnamens
london city wird ermordet aufgefunden
london city ist einer jener ungeliebten
retortenklub das spielzeug eines
ukrainischen oligarchen viele akteure in
wintertransfer erinnern mich an reale
persönlichkeiten aus dem fußball
der ukrainische klub eigentümer etwa an
roman abramowitsch von chelsea
der arrogante portugiesische cheftrainer
gleicht so mourinho in dem alkohol
verfallen ex-fußballstar könnte paul
gascoigne sein
oder george best
und beim schwulen deutschen spieler der
sich outen will denke ich unweigerlich
an thomas hitzlsberger
doch eine figur wie den ich erzähler und
helden des krimis kenne ich aus dem
englischen fußball nicht scott menschen
der assistenztrainer von london city der
ex fußballer ist nämlich nicht nur von
haus aus reich er ist auch dunkelhäutig
hat studiert ist mehrsprachig und
obendrein ziemlich zynisch
ich bin verglichen mit ein paar jungs im
team ein beschissener richard dawkins
also so etwas wie ein intellektuelles
chemie manson soll im auftrag des club
eigentümers den mord am chef trainer
aufklären
auf mich wirkt er fast zu klug für einen
fußballtrainer wenn ein trainer dem
aussieht als ich schlecht ausdrücken
kann färbt das auf das image des ganzen
klubs ab in einer ära in der die täter
viel klüger sind als früher
die handlung in karlsburg beeindruckt
mich weniger als die beißende kritik an
vielen aspekten der ersatzreligion
fußball
aspekte wie die unter den fans
verbreitete homophobie so rät menschen
dem schwulen deutschen spieler sich
keinesfalls zu outen
unser sport ist die letzte bastion für
heuchler und schwulenhasser die spieler
halten die klappe aus angst nicht vor
den anderen spielern sondern wegen der
beschimpfungen die die fans parat haben
das wäre nackter karriere selbstmord
wenn du jetzt was sagst bei solch
harscher kritik beschleicht mich doch
wieder das leise gefühl der autor hasse
den fußball ebenso wie die eingangs
zitierte polizist in ich finde nicht
dass meine kommentare extrem sind sie
sind ehrlich und realistisch und sie
stehen für die gedanken und gefühle
vieler intelligenter leute über den
fußball über fußball werden täglich
tausende zeitungsseiten gefüllt ich kann
mir vorstellen dass es schwierig für
einen auto ist eine eigene sprache zu
entwickeln
doch köln sagt genau das habe ihn an der
aufgabe gereizt ich mag
herausforderungen
aber was mich dazu verleitet zu glauben
dass die fußball literatur eine zukunft
hat ist dass dieser sport in unserem
täglichen leben einem jahr für jahr
wachsenden stellenwert genießt es zu
einer art weltsprache geworden dass
fußball mit all seinen facetten schön
und hässlich aber immer faszinierend ist
hat philip r ein deutlich
herausgearbeitet vermisst hatte mir das
spiel nicht
dafür liebte es selber viel zu sehr